Olá minhas amigas meus
amigos estou muito feliz aqui com vocês
hoje fazendo a introdução do nosso curso
sobre tratamento natural da hiperplasia
prostática benigna eu sou médico
urologista Sou formada a 25 anos e já
sou urologista pelo menos 22 anos depois
da minha formação inicial em medicina eu
fiz a residência médica em cirurgia
geral e depois eu fiz a residência
médica em urologia a minha residência
médica em cirurgia geral foi no Hospital
Universitário de Brasília e a minha
formação em urologia foi no Hospital
Santa Marcelina de São Paulo na minha
época fui o mais jovem urologista a
consegui o título da Sociedade
Brasileira de urologia o título de tibo
de especialista eu consegui esse título
mesmo antes de terminar minha residência
entre as minhas certificações destaca
eu ser board certified physician ou seja
o médico
certificado pela American board of anti
and regenerative
medicine isso é um título muito difícil
de obter e que eu acredito que menos de
C médicos no Brasil tem esse título Além
disso eu fui o primeiro médico do Brasil
a completar a formação
recode reverse cognitive decline que é
ministrado pelo renad
neurocientista Dr D Brad que foi o
primeiro médico cientista a desenvolveu
um protocolo PR reversão da doença de
alzheimer Então por muitos anos Eu
tratei hiperplazia prostática benigna
como qualquer out urologista antes de eu
entrar na medicina funcional integrativa
de estilo de vida eu tratava hipoplasia
prostática benigna com mesil doxazosina
com tansulosina com finasterida com
erida Essas são as quatro principais
drogas que são utilizadas pro tratamento
da doença então o objetivo do nosso
curso é o que te dá uma alternativa
natural e eficaz pro tratamento dessa
doença sim é possível você fazer um
tratamento totalmente natural ou ainda
nem precisa chegar a tanto vocês podem
associar os recursos
farmacológicos com os recursos
fitoterápicos e demais nutrientes nós
vamos falar de tudo isso nas nossas
aulas então eu vou dar para vocês a
visão ortodoxa e também vou dar para
vocês a visão da Medicina integrativa na
medicina funcional Ao qual eu me dedico
nos últimos o anos então esse curso é
uma grande oportunidade para você
aprender como tratar uma doença
extremamente
prevalente nos idosos A grande maioria
dos homens vai ter hpb sintomática todos
os homens vão ter alguma forma de
hiperplasia mas a grande maioria por
volta de 60 a 70% vão ter sintomas então
você que trata homens que trata pessoas
com mais de 50 a 60 anos de idade
precisa saber o mínimo sobre essa doença
que é extremamente comum e apesar da
hipoplasia prostática benigna não você
causa direta de
câncer ela tem relação sim com
prostatite e a prostatite por si só
também pode ter relação com câncer então
é importante saber desinflamar próstata
e vocês vão ver ao longo do curso que
nós temos vários recursos aí para a
gente poder desinflamar a próstata tanto
com agentes específicos pra próstata
quanto agentes que são de ação mais
sistêmica mas que também vão ser
benéficos pros portadores de hpb vocês
vão ver que o hpb tem a ver com estilo
de vida tem a ver com atividade física
com alimentação com sono com estresse
então tudo que afeta a saúde geral
também vai afetar a próstata então
fiquem ligados porque esse curso
Fantástico V te ensinar tudo que você
precisa saber a respeito dessa doença
então o nosso cronograma é o seguinte
são quatro módulos o primeiro módulo
entendendo a hiperplasia
prostática tem quatro partes primeira
parte que é hpb definição
epidemiologia bioquímica E
fisiopatologia então vamos falar sobre o
que é a
doença parte dois é sintomas comuns e os
métodos de Diagnóstico disponíveis pela
medicina mais
Ortodoxa parte três é como é que é o
estilo de vida e como é que ele afeta a
doença tanto positivamente quanto
negativamente e a parte quatro são
tratamentos ortodoxos da alopatia da
Medicina mais Ortodoxa convencional
no módulo dois nós vamos abordar os
fundamentos da fitoterapia da Medicina
automo cular então parte um introdução à
fitoterapia parte dois introdução à
medicina ortomolecular e a parte três a
segurança e eficácia dessas
[Música]
abordagens já no módulo três nós vamos
abordar substâncias naturais no
tratamento da hpb as ervas medicinais os
suplementos nutricionais e outras
abordagens naturais e no módulo 4ro são
os protocolos de tratamento a parte um
tratamentos naturais parte dois
combinação de naturais com fármacos e
três casos clínicos e encerramento do
curso Então é isso pessoal nós nos vemos
na próxima aula você é feira